nos dicen que acá es el punto medio de
jl es decir tenemos que el segmento jk
es congruente al segmento kl tienen la
misma longitud y además nos dicen que jk
es igual a 8 x menos 8
entonces este segmento de acá mide 8 x 8
y también nos dicen que kl es igual a 7
x 6 este segmento de acá mide 77 x menos
6 y a partir de esa información nos
piden determinar la longitud del
segmento j l y para eso vamos a
necesitar encontrar el valor de x y ya
teniendo el valor de x pues o bien
podemos duplicar esta cantidad porque
este es punto medio o bien podemos sumar
las longitudes de ambos segmentos para
eso no para encontrar la longitud de jl
bueno vamos a empezar encontrando el
valor de x y para encontrar el valor de
x lo que vamos a hacer es igualar estas
dos longitudes vamos a ponerle aquí que
8 x
8 x 8 es igual a 7 x 6 es igual a 7 x
menos 6 me gustaría hacer énfasis en
esta parte esta igualdad la sabemos
porque nos dicen que acá es el punto
medio de jl y por lo tanto esta longitud
es igual a esta longitud muy bien ahora
vamos a encontrar x aquí entonces
tenemos que utilizar un poquito de
álgebra lo que vamos a hacer es pasar
las x de un mismo lado así que déjame
restar 7x de ambos lados de esta
igualdad menos 7 x menos 7x y además voy
a sumar 8 de ambos lados más 8 + 8 eso
es para que las constantes queden del
lado derecho de este lado 8 x 7 x nos
queda igual a x entonces nos quedaría x
es igual a el 8 se canse el menos 8 se
cancela con el 8 y de este lado el 7 x
se cancela con el menos 7 x y por lo
tanto nos queda que x es igual a 8 menos
osea que x es igual a 2
pero ojo todavía no hemos terminado lo
que nos piden es determinar la longitud
del segmento j l bueno y para eso
podemos encontrar la de alguno de estos
y duplicarla o bien sumar ambas vamos a
hacer las dos cosas vale déjame
encontrar la longitud de jk lo voy a
poner de este lado por acá entonces jk
jk es igual a 8x menos 8 pero x es igual
a 2 entonces es 8 por 2 menos 8 2 por 8
es 16 menos 8 es igual a 8 entonces
tenemos que la longitud de jk es igual a
8 este de aquí es 8 vale y entonces
bueno como acá es punto medio oeste de
acá también va a ser igual a 8 y por lo
tanto la longitud de jl de jl es igual a
16 pero también lo podemos hacer de la
otra forma también podemos calcular
ahora la longitud de kl pues para
asegurarnos que todas las matemáticas
que estamos haciendo son consistentes si
lo hacemos de esa forma nos queda 7 por
2 o sea 14 7 por 2 este con esto es 14
menos 6 es igual a 8
y entonces una vez más nos queda que k l
es igual a 8 y por lo tanto jl es 88 o
sea 16